so I didn't I didn't watch uh I didn't
start the show with the debate and
that's because I thought it would be
better to start the show with something
that actually matters and the debate
doesn't matter and I'm not just saying
that to be contrarian or whatever I'm
not just saying that because I only
watch parts of the debate not the whole
thing so I couldn't deliver a complete
analysis of it if I wanted to though
that is the case I admit but I'm saying
it because it's true you know it just is
like this stuff it really doesn't matter
it has almost no effect
who won the debate
is the big the big now there's the
debate after the debate about who won it
well the vet had some good moments
DeSantis had some good moments uh the
others performed exactly as you'd expect
I thought they all performed exactly as
you would expect
and uh pretty much you know I've noticed
this pattern here's a really interesting
pattern that I've noticed okay it's
pretty fascinating fascinating
coincidence but what I've seen is just
watching pundits and and people the
peanut gallery after debate it seems
like if you liked uh Vivek ramaswamy
before the debates
then you think you probably will think
that he won it and if you liked DeSantis
before the debate then you'll probably
think that he won it
and if you like Mike Pence before the
debate you'll think that he won it so
that's that's the um that's the
relationship that I'm noticing that most
of the people who think that Vivek won
the debate are the ones who going into
it liked him the most
pretty fascinating again I mean who
could have seen that coming
um
the truth is that nobody had a moment
that will live in history and be
remembered nobody had any one line a
response that will be quoted 10 years
from now or even 10 seconds from now uh
nobody imploded on stage either you know
nobody went down in flames I mean it is
possible I'm not saying that no debate
has ever mattered it is possible for
someone to have a debate performance
that does have a major impact on the
political world and on their own
political fortunes for good or ill that
does happen obviously we can all think
of examples
but it doesn't usually happen and it
didn't happen last night
everybody was fine you know everyone was
fine it was fine like it was all just it
was fine
the C plus
was not fine though
um Fox was pretty terrible which is not
unexpected
they were terrible with topic selection
they were terrible with how they handled
the debate and I'll talk about that in a
moment
um as for topics election they they hit
for example they hit climate change
basically right out of the gate
and this is maybe the one clip from last
night that I'll play for you because it
gives you a good idea of where Fox is
coming from but here they are teeing up
the climate change conversation
Hawaii's governor and White House
officials said that climate change
Amplified the cost of human error and a
tropical storm hit California for the
first time in 84 years the ocean hit 101
degrees off the coast of Florida and in
the last month the heat wave in the
southwest broke records nearly 50 years
old so Alexander Diaz from Young
Americas Foundation has a question for
you all
pools consistently show that young
people's number one issue is climate
change how will you as both president of
the United States and leader of the
Republican Party calm their fears that
the Republican party doesn't care about
climate change so we want to start on
this with a show of hands
climate change raise your hand if you do
look we're not school children let's
have the debate I mean I'm happy to take
it to start by the way first time in 84.
so uh tribal storm hit California first
time in 84 years
so you're saying it happened 84 years
ago so you're saying this is the kind of
thing that does happen it's rare but it
happens
but rare things happen they just don't
happen often and so when a rare thing
happens it doesn't mean that some
unprecedented of it it's not
unprecedented it's rare by definition
that means it's not unprecedented
what caused it 84 years ago if climate
change is causing it now okay if human
cause if human man-made climate change
is causing
the tropical storm now what caused it 84
years ago
and if you're gonna tell me well uh well
so something else 84 years ago well then
couldn't it be that something else now
so there's no difference between how Fox
handled this debate and how MSNBC would
have handled it they talked about
climate change they talked about January
6th they talked about Ukraine they
talked about Trump they're probably
talking about Trump uh I don't know I
haven't I haven't seen the breakdown of
how much time was spent on each topic
but Trump trump as a topic will be
certainly in the top three in terms of
the amount times spent on it and and
that was most of it
exactly the the kind of topic selection
MSNBC would have went with
no difference
and by the way Fox did not ask any
questions about child mutilation or
gender ideology which that's the biggest
cultural issue in the country
for multiple years now is that
and there wasn't one single question
about it
and I brought this up on Twitter at one
and someone said
well there's no reason to ask because we
already know what their answers are but
they all agree
first of all if we're if we aren't
asking questions
if we're going to decide in the debate
that we're not going to ask any question
that we already know the answer to that
we would just ask no questions at all
because we know we know what they're
going to say to all of these things
but they don't all agree in fact there's
a person on that stage ASA Hutchinson
who vetoed a bill Banning child
mutilation
so they don't all agree
um you have a governor who has banned
charmulation another one who vetoed the
banum so there's a real let's have a
discussion about that
no time for that we got to talk about
climate change and other stuff
um
and this thing about climate change
being the number one issue for young
people is BS obviously
climate change is not I'm sorry I don't
care even if someone tells me that
climate change is their number one issue
it's not I don't believe you if you try
to tell me that I I just don't believe
you I don't I don't believe the polls
that's the kind of answer people give
because they think they're supposed when
someone comes to you especially if
you're younger and you're not you're not
clued in you don't know what's going on
in the world
and some surveyor comes to you and says
what are the top issues to you
and then you say uh climate change
because it sounds socially conscious it
sounds like the kind of thing you're
supposed it's a safe thing it's a safe
thing to say
um it's the kind of answer you give on a
survey because you think it's the answer
you're supposed to give
but nobody is waking up in the morning
worried about climate change
uh people don't even like talk about it
in real life
I did like to say it's his response
there the way he began his response
um objecting to the way the question was
even framed what does this raise your
hand stuff
they did that multiple times last night
raise your hand if
this is what my kids do at the dinner
table this is what they do when they're
all sitting around raise your hand if
you think vanilla is the best ice cream
flavor that's what kids like to do this
is a these are adults allegedly this is
a presidential race
can we actually talk about it and have a
cop what do you mean raise your hand
especially when it comes to an issue
like this when you can't really give
your take with a simple hand raise
not every question is yes or no
and that was my biggest problem with the
debate and uh and it's it's my problem
with how basically every presidential
debate is run
especially in the primaries I just I
hate it I hate it I think they do it
completely wrong I hate the way we
approach debates
Innovation refunds has been helping
small businesses that qualify to get a
business payroll tax refund through the
employee retention credit or also known
as the ERC that the ERC is a tax refund
for businesses that kept employees on
payroll for parts of 2020 and 2021. if
you own a business with more than five
employees you could have money waiting
to be claimed if you started your
application for the ERC but it didn't
finish it well Innovation refunds team
of independent tax attorneys specialize
in ERC application so you don't have to
worry about potential errors or
navigating complex IRS guidelines let
their Team guide you through the
remaining steps to find out if you're
eligible their dedicated team of
independent tax attorneys will help you
complete your ERC application with
confidence and peace of mind today
Innovation refunds does not provide tax
or legal advice they work with an
independent network of tax professionals
and will share information with them to
evaluate and process your claims go to
innovationrefunds.com to determine
eligibility if you qualify you could be
on your way to receiving money for your
business there's no upfront charge since
they don't get paid unless you you get
paid go to innovationrefunds.com or dial
1-843 refunds that's
innovationrefunds.com or 1843 refunds
terms and conditions apply
because the thing is they did cover some
topics that matter they talk about they
talked about the Border they talked
about crime they talked about abortion
these are topics that matter
but even there it was basically
pointless because you have eight people
on the stage and they have 90 seconds or
45 seconds or even 30 seconds in some
cases to give an answer
okay how ridiculous is that in a in a
political debate
well we're trying to figure out who
should be president
you throw a question out you have 30
seconds 30 seconds
what can you say in 30 seconds
and then of course as it always goes in
these debates if they actually start
arguing right if they if they you know
if they if they debate during the debate
the moderators jump in to shut it down
no there's not going to be any debating
sir sir
there will be no debating in this debate
those are the rules
stop nope stop debating
this is a debate not a debate stop
debating
be civil which means what does that mean
it means it means go back to giving your
canned 30-second sound bites
and they're all canned okay I know the
knock on uh someone like DeSantis
against mostly from people that decided
ahead of time they weren't gonna like
his performance no matter what he did
but uh but still the zoo his responses
are canned they're all canned what do
you think they're doing up there
are you that stupid that you think that
that there's anyone on the stage not
giving a canned response you don't think
they all sat there and rehearsed it and
they're giving rehearsed responses maybe
some of them are better at not sounding
rehearsed but they're all rehearsed and
canned all of them every time
you know why because nobody can say
anything worthwhile in 30 seconds you
can't flesh out your views you can't
explain your position
you can't do anything but give a canned
response I don't even blame them for
giving canned responses you have to
what else are you gonna do
you know if someone says um
what do you think about crime do you
have 30 seconds go
if you don't have a canned response for
that you're not gonna you won't be able
to say anything
uh what do I think about it uh let me
think you know that's what normal people
do
unless you have a canned response and
you can and you can pull into your bag
of cannons oh I got a 30 second for that
I mean these people they all have uh
they have a 30 second canned response
for each topic they have 45 seconds they
have 90 seconds they might have a two
minute
and depending on the Forum if it's a
debate then they go you know if they go
into cable news
can any of them talk about any of these
topics for more than 120 seconds at a
maximum can any of them flesh out their
views for like let's say five minutes at
a time I don't know we have we've rarely
seen it
and so
we talk about who won the debate
what do you mean by when okay the person
who wins if anyone wins it's because
they were the best at saying Snappy
clever things in 30 seconds which great
okay that's great but what does that
mean what does that tell us about them
so what so let's say that someone's the
BET someone has the best you know debate
performance in the world the best thing
you've ever seen the best of performance
all that means is that they are very
very very good
at saying clever things in 30 seconds
that they've rehearsed ahead of time but
but they don't sound rehearsed
which again I mean that is a real skill
I give you I give you a lot of props for
that it means you'd be a great cable
news contributor
but does it mean to be a great president
what is the carry over here
you might as well just have them go out
and and do a a you know a three-legged
race but put them in potato sacks and do
a you know a relay race
that'd be more entertaining at least
having to do a push-up contest on stage
it's more entertaining
it would be just as irrelevant probably
less irrelevant actually at least that
would tell us a little bit about their
physical fitness and office because this
tells us nothing
the way they handle it tells us nothing
about them it tells them does nothing
about how how they would be as president
and I hate it I don't know if I've
mentioned that I hate it but I really do
um and then you have the live audience
there
what is the live audience doing in there
like why does anyone question this why
do you have a live why do we need a live
yeah the debate should be live it should
be broadcast live but why do you need an
audience in the room
what does that do what would get what
difference does that this is supposed to
be a conversation about serious issues
why do we need train seals clapping in
the background all that means is that
someone can say something really
ordinary and and it will sound epic if
they get the Applause right so they can
say oh yeah well
I think you're wrong about that and then
the crowd goes oh yeah
and then later on the pundits we'll talk
about how that was a great moment
you know I thought it was a great line
uh you know when the candidate said that
the other one was wrong about that crowd
reaction was great it was a great moment
it was a defining moment for him that's
going to change everything
so here's how the debate should go okay
I'm not just criticizing without having
a solution here's what you do
primaries
you let three or four people
into the debate not any more than that I
mean there were people who were
complaining that there weren't enough
people in there people complaining that
oh well Larry Elder someone else should
have been but you thought there should
be more people on the stage that's what
you think that's how we improve this
no there should be three or four people
you take the top three or four people we
don't need the the guys that no one's
heard of we don't need the governor of
North Dakota
10 people live in that state half of
them have never heard of their of their
governor the rest of us have no idea
okay I mean I could announce for
president tomorrow and I would pull
higher than the governor of North Dakota
not much higher but I would pull higher
like guaranteed
so he's irrelevant we don't need him in
there uh we don't need we don't need ASA
Hutchinson in there what what who's
voting for ASA Hutchinson what audience
what what is Asa Hutchinson's base if
you talk to one person in your life
and you ask him who's you know what's
the politician you support they say ASA
Hutchinson
what do we need Chris Christie for he's
not a serious candidate either so just
give up the the three or four top guys
put them in a room
nobody in the audience
you give them topics and you let them
argue about the topics that's all that's
all the moderators should do that's how
you moderate a debate you say Okay
candidates your first topic is the
Border
then maybe give them each three minutes
for opening statements just to kind of
lay out opening statement and then
you say okay go 45 minutes talk about it
and then you sit back and you just let
them talk that's it
you just sort of have a conversation
like normal human beings do so we can
actually hear them flesh it out hear how
they defend their their point here just
hear it let can we let it play out a
little bit
presidential debate between two people
even more so
you know you have the two presidents two
presidential candidates you should have
uh you know it's a two two and a half
hour two two and a half hour debate you
have maybe five or six topics maybe at
most and you just you throw out the
topic they get 30 45 minutes
uh 20 minutes at a minimum
and you just let them talk about it you
don't need to jump in just at sir stop
being mean you're being mean to him your
interrupting it's a little bit to it be
nice please and thank you we don't need
that why do we need that
it's all wrong all this stuff is so
incredibly ridiculous and insulting
and uh I talked about it for 15 minutes
anyway but
what can I do hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there